[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اتهامات متبادله بين الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس والقيادي السابق في
حركه فتح محمد دحلان فقد البح عباس الى
ضلوع دحلان في قضيه اغتيال الرئيس
الفلسطيني الراح ياسر عرفات وقياديين
فلسطينيين اخرين بينما توعد دحلان بالكشف
عما وصفها باكاذيب في خطاب عباس نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر نناقشه في
محورين هل من دلالات لتوقيت الاتهامات
المتبادله بين عباس
ودحلان وما تداعيات هذه الاتهامات
المتبادله على السلطه
الفلسطينيه خلال اجتماع للمجلس الثوري
لحركه فتح شن الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس
هجوما على القيادي السابق في حركه فتح
محمد دحلان عباس اتهم دحلان بالمسؤوليه عن
اغتيال قيادات في الحركه والمشاركه في
اغتيال قائد كتائب القسام السابق ولمح الى
مسؤوليته عن تسميم الرئيس الفلسطيني
الراحل ياسر عرفات اتهامات رد عليها دحلان
على صفحته على فيسبوك فورا متوعدا بالكشف
عما وصفها باكاذيب عباس
من شهر 4
2004 في صحيفه البيان الاماراتيه دحلان
يقول مهمه عرفات
انتهت من الذي قتل ياسر عرفات خصوصا وين
احنا
لايصين مين
اللي وصل السم
لياسر هجوم غير مسبوق يشنه الرئيس
الفلسطيني على من كان حليفا مفترض اتهامات
بالضلوع بالقتل واخرى اشد خطوره وتلمح الى
دور ما لمحمد دحلان في تسميم عرفات عباس
الغاضب يفصل ولا يلمح في ملفات اخرى فسته
اشخاص قتلوا بايعاز من دحلان يذكرهم عباس
بالاسم وثمه دور ما لعبه الرجل وفقا
لروايه عباس في اغتيال اسرائيل للقيادي في
حماس صلاح شحاده عام
2002 دحلان اذا في خطاب عباس ليس عدوا
حركه فتح بل لحماس ايضا وعلى الجميع
والحال هذه ان يتكاتف في مواجهته لكن
لماذا غضب عباس كثيرا في عام
2014 بينما تواريخ الوقائع التي يذكرها
تعود الى ما قبل عام 2004 مات عرفات قبل
عشر سنوات من تلميح عباس الى دور لدحلان
في مقتله ليس هو من كشف تسميم عرفات بل
تحقيق اجرته الجزيره وفي سنواته الاخيره
كان عرفات محاص
والاثنان عباس ودحلان طليقين بل ان الحمله
الامريكيه لعزل عرفات الجاته الى التنازل
عن بعض صلاحياته لرئيس وزرائه انذاك محمود
عباس رد دحلان على اتهامات عباس كان موجزا
فهي نموذج متكامل من الكذب والتضليل
ونموذج للغباء والجهل حسب ما ذكر على
صفحته على فيسبوك اما غضب عباس
فيعزل الى شعوره بان اطراف
تهيؤ دحلان لدور اكبر وربما على حساب عباس
لذلك لجا الاخير في الشهور الاخيره الى
محاصره اتباع دحلان في غزه واوقف رواتب
نحو 100 منهم ولاحق جمعيات قيل ان زوجه
دحلان تديرها في غزه وبعض مخيمات لبنان
واخيرا اتهمه ضمنا بدور في مقتل عرفات
وتلك لحرق ما تبقى من اوراقه في حال كان
يحتفظ ببعض منها
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفنا من رام الله
موفق مطر عضو المجلس الثوري لحركه فتح ومن
غزه الكاتب والناشط السياسي طلال الشريف
اهلا بضيفي الكريمين وابدا بضيفي من رام
الله السيد موفق مطر الخلاف بين الرئيس
عباس وبين دحلان ليس بالجديد ما الذي دفع
بالرئيس محمود عباس الى الاعلان الانما ما
اعلنه امام المجلس الثوري بخصوص السيد
دحلان
لا خلاف بين الرئيس محمود عباس ابو مازن
ومحمد
دحلان الخلاف الحقيقه ان حركه فتح حركه
التحرير الوطني الفلسطيني والسلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه ومنظمه التحرير الفلسطيني ايضا
هي التي قررت او حركه فتح اولا قد قررت
تطهير صفوفها من كل الشخوص الذين يحاولون
التجنح ويح وون اختلاق التبعيه وكل الشخوص
الذين بدات تاريخهم باجرام وفساد وانتهى
ايضا كي كذلك باجراء الم
فساد لاننا لان حركه فتح وهي العمود
الفقري وكما اكد الرئيس ابو مازن لحركه
التحرر الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ولاننا نواجه
منعطفا خطيرا على القضيه الفلسطينيه
ولاننا نمر بمرحله قد تكون مصيريه و هذا
يتطلب ان تكون حر هذه المرحيه
صلبه نعم ما بعد ما بعد 29 عه ما بعد
المفاوضات وما بعد وفي ظل انسداد وفي ظل
التعنت الاسرائيلي ولاننا نواجه الان ذات
الملامح التي واجهت الرئيس عرفات قبل
عمليه اغتياله عمليه تشفيف الرئيس عرفات
عمليه تشويه الرئيس عرفات عمليه رفع
الغطاء السياسي عن عرفات عمليه التهيئه
لاغتيال عرفات تشابه تماما المرحله التي
نمر بها لذلك قرر رئيس الشعب الفلسطيني
ورئيس حركه فتح وقائدها العام ان يطلع
قاده حركه فتح ويطلع ايضا الشعب الفلسطيني
على هذه الحقائق لذلك كان لان الرئيس ابو
مازن ليس لانه يستشعر خطرا على حياته وحسب
وانما اراد ان يضع الشعب الفلسطيني بعد ان
اجمع كل المحللين والخبراء وكل قاض فتح
ايضا اننا نمر بذات المرحله التي مر بها
مرت بها القضيه الفلسطينيه ومرت ب مر بها
المشروع الوطني الفلسطيني قبل اغتيال يا
سيد طلال الشريف ضيفي من من غزه اتهامات
ثقيله قيلت من قبل اعلى راس في السلطه
الفلسطينيه الرئيس محمود عباس بالخيانه
وبالقتل وتهم اخرى وجهت للسيد محمد دحلان
هل لكم تعليق على بدايه لما هذا
الان وكان الاستاذ موفق يتحدث عن ان هناك
نصر كبير سيذهب ابو مازن لاحراز في الوقت
الذي يعني تتحدث كل التحليلات على ان
الرئيس في موقف ضعيف وهو ذاهب على ما يبدو
للتنازلات
الكبرى
وهوب انا لم اق ان ان الرس قذف كره من
اللهب في حركه تحرر الوطني الفلسطيني فتح
التيار
المركزي عف لنبقى في موضوع هذه الحلقه
عفوا عف ضي
الريم ضيفي الكريمين السيد موفق وكذلك
السيد طلال على كل نحن الان امام قضايا
جنائيه وسياسيه موجهه للسيد محمد دحلان
سالتك هل لديك تفسير سيد طلال في توقيت
هذه الها نعم التفسير التسير
الت التفسير يتحدث عن نفسه في الوقت الذي
تطلق ك سرايا القدس مئات الصواريخ على
اسرائيل ونحن في حاله حرب حقيقيه مع
اسرائيل ينضم ابو مازن الى الاعلام
الاسرائيلي لاضعاف الروح المعنويه للشعب
الفلسطيني ويرمي بكره من اللهب في المجتمع
الفلسطيني لحرقه لاضعاف في النهايه لكي لا
من يعارضه ل هل يستطيع السيد دحلان نفي
التهم الموجهه اليه من قبل الرئيس
الفلسطيني سيدي هذه التهم لا يجوز ان يشوه
الرئيس الناس ويرمي بها جزافا على الاعلام
هناك ثلاث قضايا تحدثتم عنها قضيه صلاح
شحاده الشهيد صلاح شحاده وقد تحدث وقد كان
هناك تحقيقات وتبين من هم متور ين وكلام
الرئيس كان بان يعني كلام فاضي انه في
واحد قال انه كذا كذا هذه مش مش دلائل ومش
اثباتات ولا يجوز ان يتحدث بهذه الطريقه
الرئيس اثنين موضوع الرئيس عرفات لماذا
يتحدث الان في الاعلام هناك توفيق الطراوي
رئيس لجنه التحقيق لماذا لا يخرج ويقول
لنا النتائج طيب هذا سؤال موجه لضيف السيد
موفق مثر فيما يتعلق لماذا لجا الرئيس
محمود عباس الى قول ذلك بشكل علني وبث
مدار في المجلس الثوري وقدمته وسائل
الاعلام الفلسطينيه هل الرساله موجهه فقط
للسيد محمد دحلان ام موجهه لجهات
اخرى نعم هي موجهه في الحقيقه لكل الجهات
التي استخدمت محمد دحلان من هي هذه الجهات
لكل القوى والدول نعم اولا اسرائيل
الاداره الامريكيه قوى اقليميه في المنطقه
دول عربيه ايضا ما زالت حتى هذه اللحظه
تستخدم ايضا محمد دحلان هذه هذه هذه
الكلمه التي القاها الرئيس اب ابو مازن هي
في الحقيقه ليست موجهه فقط الى قياده حركه
فتح في المجلس الثوري كانت موجهه الى
الشعب الفلسطيني والرئيس بذاته هو الذي
امر باخراج هذه الكلمه الى الشعب
الفلسطيني لا يهرب ارجو ان يهرب احد
ويختبئ وراء المقاومه المقاومه التي اطلقت
الصواريخ هي التي نفسها تعهدت ب هدئه وصفت
الاعمال العدا المقاومه بالاعمال العدائيه
فلا يهرب وليبقى في صلب الموضوع الاخ طلال
الان الرئيس ابو مازن الرئيس ابو مازن
لانه يواجه مرحله خطيره في حياه الشعب
الفلسطيني لانه مسؤول ايضا ابو مازن لم
يوزع التهم ابو مازن قال ان كل هذه
الملفات بحثت عبر لجان تحقيق وذكرها ان
عزام الاحمد
حقق حق سييد موفق بما انك اشرت الى لجان
عفوا الى لجان التحقيق سي سييد موفق بما
انك اشرت الى لجان التحقيق ومن بينها ما
يتعلق بحماس وقد خرجت اللجنه بمجموعه
نتائج لماذا المطالبه والاعلان الان عن
هذه التهم لماذا لم يقدم السيد دحلان
للمحاكمه وقد كان موجودا والتهم كانت يعني
لتوها قد وقعت وتستر واذا كانت حقيق يجيب
دح يجيب دح يجيب دح يجيب عفوا سيدال
السؤال طبعا محمد دحلان محمد دحلان منذ
تاريخ فصله خارج خارج فلسطين هو مقيم هو
في الامارات ويعمل مستشارا امنيا لدوله
الامارات العربيه الان ويعمل ايضا خادما
يعمل خادما لاحد الامراء في
فيح
مفضل
شوف انت كنت تشحد من محمد عيب عليك سيد
طلال سيد ط
سيد طلال سيد طلال فيما يتعلق عفوا سيد
طلال سيد طلال سيد طلال عفوا عفوا المساله
هذا البرنامج ليس للاتهامات الشخصيه عفوا
سيد طلال سيد طلال سيد طلال سيد طلال عفوا
سيد ط اسمعوني الاتهامات كثيره موجهه
للسيد دحلان ليس من الان ولكن منذ سنوات
طويله السؤال الكبير الان الموجه للسيد دح
ربما قد يدعم بشكل او باخر ما يوجه له من
اتهامات من اين لسيد دحلان بكل هذه
الاموال اي اموال هو دحلان عنده اموال ليس
له اموال دحلان يعمل بمساعدات دوله
الامارات يحضرها للناس لا ادري ان عنده
اموال خلي موفق يقول لنا وين الاموال هي
قدش هي و وكيف جابها دحلان
اها سؤال مجه لك سيد موفق فيما يتعلق بما
هو موجه من تهم فساد والى غير ذلك للسيد
دحلان نع الملفات كلها جميعها جميعها
وذكرها الرئيس ابو مازن ذكر بعضها الرئيس
ابو مازن دون التفاصيل وانما ذكر عناوين
بعض ملفات الفساد هذه والتي جنى منها محمد
دحلان الملايين الملفات كلها عند القضاء
ولكني انا اسال الاخ طلال الان لماذا لا
ياتي محمد دحلان وهو الذي له الحق بان
يعود الى فلسطين باي لحظه ويدافع نفس عن
نفسه امام القضاء الفلسطيني داحو يجيب عن
هذا السؤال داح يجيب عن هذا السؤال الى
الى فطين ودا سي ط تفضل لماذا لا يحضر
يدافع عن نفسي مادامت هذه التهم جزافيه
وكما وصفها السيد دحلان بانها يعني مظلله
وتنم عن جهل ان خ
ا اسمع طيب اسمع الاجابه اسمع
الاجابه اسمع الاجابه لقد حضر دحان في في
العام حضر قبل هذا وقد هجم بيته وانت تعرف
القصه تماما لكن محمد دحلان يقول على رؤوس
الاشهاد اذا كانت هناك لجنه تحقيق وطنيه
تبحث كل القضايا فليتفضل ابو مازن يرفع
يده بشرط الا يكون ابو مازن متدخلا في
الموضوع وهو جاهز للعوده في اي
وقت من قال لك انه لن يعود سيعود ان شاء
الله هو الرئيس
كمان اذا في في ظل عفوا ضيفي الكريمين سيد
موفق سيد طلال في ظل هذا الجدل وهذا
النقاش الحاد ماذا عن تاثير كل ما يجري
على السلطه الفلسطينيه على مجال المفاوضات
الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه
ووضع الدوله الفلسطينيه في ظل كل ذلك
سنناقشه ولكن بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
نناقش فيها الاتهامات المتبادله بين عباس
ودحلان بشان تسميم عرفات واغتيال قياديين
فلسطينيين اخرين واجد التحيه لضيف في رام
الله وفي غزه سيذ موفق كنت ق اشرت قبل
قليل الى جهات خارجيه تريد ان تؤثر على
المسار على تؤثر على الرئيس الفلسطيني
وبالتالي هو دفعه للخروج هذه المره هل من
تفصيل في هذه النقطه وعلاقتها بالتاثير
على مجريات التفاوض الفلسطيني
الاسرائيلي نعم اود ان اقول انه لم يعد
هنالك من تاثير لمحمد دحلال لا على السلطه
ولا على حركه فتح ولا على اي مجال سياسي
يخص النظام السياسي وحتى منظمه التحرير او
السلطه الوطنيه او حركه فتح بكل قواعدها
وكل اطرها لانه تم فعلا قصقصه اجنحه وريش
اجنحه محمد دحلان اذا بقي له اتباع فهو
لانه يصرف عليهم ليس اكثر هذا اولا ساقول
لك مدى تاثير محمد دحلان عندما يحضر رئيس
الشباك الاسرائيلي بنفسه الى المقاطعه
عندما استشعرت المخابرات الاستخبارات
الاسرائيليه والمخابرات الاسرائيليه عندما
استشعرت ان لدى اللجنه المركزيه قرارا
بتجميد وفصل محمد دحلان جاء ليهدد الرئيس
ابو مازن بانكم اذا فعلتم يهدد الرئيس حتى
لا تاخذ اللجنه المركزيه القرار بهذا لكن
قرار اللجنه المركزيه كان واضحا وقرار
الرئيس كان واضحا وبلغ به رئيس الشباك
حينها وكان ذلك في في 2010 نهايه 2010
وتقريبا في بدايه 2011 قال له ملفات محمد
دحلان لدى القضاء الفلسطيني ولا دخل لكم
بذلك واذا اقتضى الامر واذا قضى القضاء
الفلسطيني بمحاكمه دحلان واعدامه بالنهايه
في المناره سنفعل وضي القضاء الفلسطيني
منذ العام 2004 الى الان فيما يتعلق بهذه
الملفات كل الملفات نعم كل الملفات كل
الملفات التي ذكرها الرئيس ما زالت منظوره
امام القضاء الفلسطيني واستطيع ان اقول لك
وايضا تسجل هذه سابقه للجزيره ايضا قبل
ايام فقط قليله انا استدعيت الى النيابه
العامه
و اخذوا مني اقوالا حول موضوع الاغتيال
بخليل الزبن في غزه هذه الملفات ما زالت
مفتوحه حتى اللحظه والنيابه العامه تحقق
في كل الملفات التي اتهم بها محمد دحلان
بشكل او باخر الرئيس لم يقل ان محمد دحلان
دس السم ل
لكنه المح الى ال اللواء الطيراوي وهو
رئيس اللجنه الوطنيه للتحقيق في اغتيال
المرحوم ابو عمار ايه بعد ان قدم ارهاصات
عن الانشقاقات وارهاصات عن جرائم وفساد
محمد دحلان ومن حق الرئيس ايضا ان يسال من
قتل ياسر عرفات وجه السؤال وايضا عندما
سال الان الاخ طلال انه لماذا لم يعلن
اللواء التراوي اللواء التراوي قبل حوالي
شهر تقريبا قال في مؤتمر صحفي نحن نعلم ان
اسرائيل هي القاتل الرئيس لياسر عرفات
لكننا نريد وضع اليد على الشخص الذي دس
السم لياسر عرفات انكشيه اغتيال ولدينا
ولدينا بينات في هذا الخصوص بما انك اشرت
لقضيه اغتيال الرئيس الفلسطيني الراحل
ياسر عرفات وهان سؤالي موجه للسيد طلال
الشريف تغم ثقيله موجهه للسيد محمد دحلان
وهو فقط اكتفى برد عن طريق
الفيسبوك رد بسيط واتهم الرئيس الفلسطيني
بالتضليل وان هذه التخم فيها غبا
وجوفه رده ليس في مستوى التهم الموجه اليه
وهذا ما قد يميل بالكف الى ان تهم
حقيقيه شوف يعني اذا كان القصه لها علاقه
بالجانب النفسي فانا اقول انه الرئيس هو
الاكثر حقدا على ياسر عرفات وهو صاحب
المصلحه في تغييب ياسر عرفات واذا
كان
الوضع في
داخل سيد طلال سيد طلال ما قاله الرئيس
الفلسطيني ليس
عف ل عفوا مقيل ليس كلاما عاطفيا هذا كلام
يصدر من رئيس دوله اي انه مؤسس على قواعد
وال مسؤول عن كلمه يتحدثها وانت تعرف يا
ال سي
سي يا سيد يا سيد الرئيس لا يعرف
مج
اسرنا ان نستمع لبعضنا
سع صمع ال بعضنا عفوا عفوا يعني بلا
مشاحنه
عاطفيه
الطريقه يا موفق
سيد موفق يتكلم
رجاء اسمع بس افهم يا رجل هل الطريقه
لمحاكمه اي مجرم او قاتل هي الاعلان في
التلفزيون وتشويه الناس دون وثائق ودون
محاكمات عيب مش صحيح هذا الحكي مش منطقي
لا يجوز استخدام الاشاعات والكذب ما دامت
اشاعات لماذا لم يتحرك السيد دحلان الى
القضاء حتى يفند هذه
بل ويدين من اطلقها لماذا لم يرد محمد
دحلان هو
سيت سيت ولكن ولكن يا سيد من الاولى على
من اتهم ان يحضر الادله ويذهب الى المحكمه
لا وتشويه الناس الادله ل القضاء
الفلسطينيي
مفق سيد موفق فيما يتعلق بتاثير كل ما
يجري على مسار القضيه الفلسطينيه هناك بعض
المصادر تربط بين خروج الرئيس بهذه
التصريحات انما مرده الى ضغوط يتعرض لها
الرئيس الفلسطيني خاصه من قبل الجانب
الامريكي والاسرائيلي فيما يتعلق
بالموافقه على الاتفاق الاطاري وبالتالي
يتم التلويح له بمحمد دحلان كبديل في حال
عدم خضوعه هل توافقون على هذا
التحليل اطلاقا محمد دحلان لم يعد له وجود
على الاطلاق في حركه فتح ولا يمكن ان ياتي
رئيسا للشعب الفلسطيني الى من العمود
الفقري لحركه التحرر الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
اي من حركه هذا اولا هذا هذا هذا اولا ولا
يمكن ان ياتي مستخدما للاداره الامريكيه
ومستخدما للشباك ومستخدما للقوى اقليميه
ومستخدما لاستخبارات عربيه ايضا ان يكون
رئيسا للشعب الفلسطيني الشعب الفلسطيني
اعظم من ان ياتي عليه رئيسا استخدم ومتهما
بالفساد
وبجرافيك انت تعمل تتهم مثل الرئس تتهم
مث له تاريخ مشرف في هذا الشعب وليس وليس
بمثل هذه الصوره التي يظهر فها لا يمكن ان
يقبل الشعب الي
اسمع اسمع اسمع ضيفي السيد طلال الشريف و
يتعلق بهذه بهذه التحاليل بما نقلته بعض
المصادر عن اسباب هذا الخروج من قبل
الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس نعم نعم نعم
قبل ذلك نفس الطريقه
يستخدمها موفق
في رمي التهم جزافا على التعامل مع
الامريكان ومره بده يجيب لاسلحه لل لسيف
طب انتم قلتوا جاب صفقه او بطلب صفقه
اسلحه لسيف القذافي عشان يحارب الامريكان
اللي هو عميل لهم عيب يا رجل عيب استحي
عاد موضوع الان التوقيت الان هو ان ابو
مازن في مازق حقيقي ذهب لوحده للفخ قد
نصحه الجميع بعدم الذهاب
للمفاوضات مع كيري بهذه
الطريقه عفوا سيد طلال ما ينقل ما ينقل
غير ذلك انما يهدد الان الرئيس الفلسطيني
كما تقول بعض المصادر ويلوح له بالسيد
دحلان كبديل حتى يتنازل وتالي هذه
لمصلحته لم يتحدث هو راح متنازل اصلا اللي
راح وهو منقسم لا انا كنت بتوقع يجي على
غزه عشان يتصالح مع حماس ويقوى الموقف
الفلسطيني مش يضعف فتح ويرمي كتل من اللهب
على الناس عشان يقوي موقفه هذا الرئيس
اللي رايح لموقف كسر عظم مع الامريكان اذا
كنا متصورين ذلك يذهب وهو ضعيفا ومكسر ومه
ي موقفه بالذين يؤمنون بالمشروع الوطني وب
الذين يؤمنون بالقضيه الفلسطينيه وذين يع
يعتبرون انهم ينتمون للهويه الوطنيه ابو
مازن لا يقوي موقفه بالذين لا يؤمنون باله
الط ولا يقوي
موقف الكريمين عفوا السيد موفق وط لنتكلم
لنتكلم بف لنتكلم بوقائع وليس بلغه عاطفيه
في تحليل الوضع الان ان كان الرئيس
الفلسطيني صلب فيما يتعلق بتفاوض مع الج
الامريكي وما يطرحه ام انه في وضع هش
وبالتالي يتم التلويح له بالسيد دحلان
بوقائع وليس بعاطفه لا لا لا لا لا هو لا
احد يلوح بح هو يا موفق يا موفق اسمعني
اسمعني هو عمليا الشخصيه الكاريزميه
القويه الاولى في فتح هو محمد دحلان كان
سابقا وما زال الان هي مالهاش علاقه بمن
ياتي هو ابو مازل مخلد بضل له هذه الشخصيه
في حركه
فتح فتح
تهر
وين عف محمد
دحلان ت محمد دحلان عارن محمد دحلان
ومجموعه قاده فتح العظام هدول اللي انتم
بتهمهم هم اللي كنا بنعرفهم
وبنشوف البرنامج للاسف من رام الله موفق
مطر عضو المجلس الثوري لحركه فتح ومن غزه
طلال الشريف الكاتب والناشط السياسي شكرا
ليفي الكريمين ب تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما ورا نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء